but in Essen investors probably wish
they'd gotten rid of their shares a
while ago few here heeded the protests
people were proud the Western German
city was home to the headquarters of
energy giants rwe
and Eon they were once its biggest
taxpayers now essence been hit hard
license filling doesn't animal usually
were able to make up shortfalls of this
kind by adjusting the budget in other
ways but I'm not convinced that we'll be
able to do that this time as good Inc
since 2011 the city's lost about 700
million euros in tax revenue after the
Fukushima disaster Germany decided to
radically switch tracks in energy
production laws were passed to go
nuclear free that affected Essen because
atomic power was a major reason why RWE
shares paid dividends and for far too
long investors thought it would continue
it didn't Roman can get four Dean's
uncle if you don't earn money you can't
pay dividends when earnings were high we
paid out a lot to shareholders that's a
fact but when we earn less shareholders
suffer to the other MIT and that
suffering won't end any time soon
the energy giants are now having to
invest in renewables projects like this
offshore wind park that's expensive and
jobs involved are a long way from Essen
but some companies continue to act like
climate change is just an ugly rumor
they fought pit closures for years but
the last black coal mine in Germany will
finally wind up operations in 2018 such
operations have received billions in
subsidies over the years that's over now
but ground coal operations are still
going strong and it's also a climate
killer rwe
doesn't seem to mind it's still strip
mining lignite despite environmental
concerns the company seems to believe in
a kind of divine approval Anatole Lago
de gand gave us a great deposit and
we're bringing up the richest seam here
in this strip mined in Targa ball
the mining process alone releases
massive amounts of harmful fine dust
into the air and burning it emits vast
quantities of co2 still policymakers
have been reluctant to stop lignite
mining completely the energy companies
and unions have worked in close alliance
to keep the industry alive the hawaiian
remind them is embraced in our common
interest to stand up for both the jobs
here and the lignite that's mine and
it's not only mine because of the jobs
but also to make germany competitive it
feels like 40% of germany's energy
production is still churned out by coal
powered facilities a statistic that
outrages protesters and if they don't
raise their voices nothing will change
[Music]